what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so I don't normally do this but I
am amped about Scot Snyder's Justice
League so we're gonna kind of split this
and and we're gonna well you guys will
see what I'm talking about when we when
we get to the end of the video but um
this is this is pretty awesome likelike
Snyder's I was a little I wasn't really
unsure
I mean Snyder's one of those riders I'll
read anything he writes but Snyder's
always been associated with Batman right
like he wrote Black Mirror before DC
rebooted in 2011 after DC rebooted he
wrote the whole new 52 Batman run which
is still you know I would consider to be
one of the greatest Batman runs of all
time you look at how he writes and it's
really interesting because what this
does is it shows as Snyder's actually a
really versatile writer most people are
familiar with Scott Snyder through his
work on Batman and that was a very slow
in paced book because Batman's very slow
and pace by and large and this it's
really more of just like world-building
and it'll actually roll in with the
flash mythos quite nicely so initially
what this does is it basically picks up
with the aftermath of basically Dark
Knight's medal the big take away from
that was that the source wall was
cracked and the multiverse was basically
bleeding energy and so what's what's
happened following the events of Dark
Knight's Medal is we have a clock that's
counting down and when it reaches zero
the multiverse will basically die that's
really what's been going on since Dark
Knight's metal happened but with with
the with regards to the crack that
happened in the source wall what it
means is it opens like a whole new can
of worms for riders in terms of bringing
in things you know bringing back
characters that we didn't or that that
we hadn't seen in a long time like
imperiex that really matters to you but
also bringing in characters that we've
never heard of before who were just part
and parcel to the source wall and their
story was never explained and so when
you get into this whole thing it's super
cool because initially this picks up
with just some some object or some
concept from the source wall just like
bricky free and careening towards earth
and so what you end up doing is you end
up switching over to the Justice League
in the middle of a conflict and that's
really an important thing here because
when it comes to the way Snyder writes
more often than not he sort of starts
things off but if you look at what he's
been doing so far you can basically
treat Dark Knight's medal and then this
me no justice league no justice and then
his actual DC Universe Justice League
run because rubber you up from rebirth
to DC Universe you can basically treat
these like you did Batman like his
Batman run right like if you read them
individually you had quarter vials of
the knight of owls and then death of the
family and then Batman in game and if
you read them individually then they
just kind of seem cool but if you read
them as a cohesive unit it's a great big
huge
story and that's what this is you go
from Dark Knight's metal which is
Barbados and the fact that Batman had a
massive impact on history and Barbados
has been trying to break into the
universe ever since and then you have
the dark multiverse which arises Dark
Knights metal ends the multiverse source
wall is crack released the source walls
cracked and that means that like the
multiverse is essentially dying then you
go into Justice League no justice which
is the aftermath and then you pick up
with this which is a continued aftermath
and what we do after the source wall is
cracked so initially what is up
happening is they're basically fighting
against like these in the and earth all
men more or less nothing super
spectacular but it's not designed to be
instead because this is a return to
familiarity for the Justice League the
big thing that really that's really
going on here is Martian Manhunter is
kind of the central focal point for the
team we're not given a whole lot of
information at the outset in terms of
what Martian Manhunter was doing and
that really doesn't seem to be a focus
of DC at the moment you know he's just
basically returned and will get some
measure of an explanation here but in
reality I think DC's kind of banking on
the reaction that they got in the sense
that fans are more excited to see
Martian Manhunter returning then they
really care about where it is that he's
been there just like we don't care where
he's been just bring him back and then
now that he's here they're just like
okay that's what I want let's just let's
go like don't care about the backstory
let's just go
that's kinda what fans have been
shooting for when it came to his
character and so ultimately of course
this is kind of an interesting thing
because as he's going through and
essentially you know helping these guys
out he begins to get this realization
that there's a much bigger plan going on
here then what initially seems to be the
case and so what this does is it
switches to Vandal Savage now this is
where the true the true ability of Scott
Snyder comes out Scott Snyder is a great
writer in the sense that he can
basically make a lot of stir over here
to keep you from looking over there but
then suddenly when you look over there
you realize oh my god like it's it's
this amazing it's this amazing thing
that he does it's super cool to watch it
happen but but picking up with Vandal
Savage it's pretty awesome because
Vandal Savage is whole plan here like
this whole thing was basically his
working you know and that's kind of what
you would expect but then suddenly out
of nowhere he's just like no no no no
your plan will ultimately fail and the
reason why is because he's being told
that by Lex Luthor and it's the coolest
thing because what this means is that
Lex Luthor has essentially gone back to
being a bad guy more or less now this is
one of those things where the Justice
League sort of picks up on that having
presumably already happened and so we
can essentially say that like Brian
Michael Bendis is Superman in Action
Comics and scott Snyder's Justice League
will basically meet in the
you know and and it'll essentially give
us this this sort of road like we can go
from here sort of trace back or we can
go from Bendis and trace forward but
basically we'll see Lex Luthor go back
to being a bad guy which in reality was
only ever a matter of time but it also
sucks I mean the nature of comics you
were reading long enough the nature of
comics as nothing stays changed forever
everything goes back to the status quo
eventually but still you know what is up
happening is they basically come to this
realization that the plan of Vandal
Savage was to basically rip away the
Earth's crust to kind of set the moon in
a position to where it would start it
would simply start creating all kinds of
problems pull the Earth's crust off and
then whatever happens what happens and
this results in the Justice League
destroying the moon weird but still
following this they all basically begin
kind of banding together like they they
end up in the the mindscape more or less
and this is when Mars Martian Manhunter
reveals to the Justice League what they
don't know that something's broken off
from the source wall and it's careening
towards Earth and this is kind of the
cool thing because initially when I saw
this it's like okay so they're gonna
have like weeks or months to prepare in
order to figure out what this thing is
and it's gonna be this big long
drawn-out scenario what we're gonna find
out what's going on and then enough
Martian Manhunter is like it's gonna be
here in three minutes so we're kind of
screwed if it's here to destroy the
world and his and it's funny because
again this is one of those things that
Justice League largely deals with like
worldwide calamities that's the nature
of what the Justice League does it deals
with worldwide events but at the same
time it's not our kind of turns it on
his head a little bit and saying like
yeah it's like a worldwide calamity
that's gonna be here in three minutes so
like the apocalypse will be here by the
time this commercials over then it is
crazy like it's a crazy situation and so
switching back over to Lex Luthor this
is one of the coolest things because Lex
Luthor what seems to have been what
seems to have happened here is Lex
Luthor seems to have found a way to
harness the sage force now this again
goes back into the flash comics and
initially I didn't know that was gonna
be a thing I mean thanks because I think
I tweeted it out or you guys mentioned
in the comments the last video and then
also it was it was Joshua Williamson who
basically tweeted it out but these new
forces would be would would play a much
larger role in the DC Universe overall
and I didn't entirely know what that
meant and that's one of the great things
about what's going on with DC Comics is
you basically have all these riders who
are crafting their own individual
stories but here and they're small
things happen or sometimes even big
things happen that will impact the
entire universe going forward but the
fact remains here that with lex luthor
he basically sees it like freezes of
Vandal Savage
Dimon's
himself to be the more capable warrior
here and the result is that the forces
of an au savage hand themselves over to
Lex Luthor who promptly kills them all
and it's like it's like God in heaven
it's it's insane and so we get this sort
of back and forth for a second where
Snyder kind of jumps between the Justice
League and Vandal Savage and what we end
up finding out here is that because of
the extent of the event that's going on
the fact that this seems to be a power
beyond the Justice League's ability to
control that what Martian Manhunter has
done he's essentially called in like all
the reserves and he's called in Jon
Stewart now Jon Stewart being brought in
here is like hey look you need to join
neo come back to the Justice League like
you need to be part of the team not only
that with regards to Lex Luthor what he
does kind of taunting Vandal Savage a
little bit he was like what you don't
understand here is that you need
something bigger than this but this is
one of the important things to bear in
mind Vandal Savage is not oblivious to
everything Vandal Savage is totally
aware of like all these energy sources
out there like the sage force to still
force all that kind of stuff and it sort
of makes sense because remember when
Scott Schneider wrote Dark Knight's
metal that was basically all predicated
on the writing of Grant Morrison which
we know has been a huge inspiration for
Scott Snyder in his Batman storytelling
and so when you look at Grant Morrison's
run and dealing with all these meta
textual commentaries and then you take
Scott Snyder's run and build on top of
that then it makes perfect sense because
he's been one of those characters that's
been around for so long it makes sense
that someone like him being as old as he
is would be well versed in pretty much
everything about the various forces of
the universe and so when Lex Luthor kind
of seizes control Vandal Savage is like
you don't really know what you're doing
here like you have no idea the forces
that you're messing with and in where he
begs and pleads Lex Luthor's response is
I know exactly what I'm doing and
essentially Lex Luthor has reformed the
Legion of Doom
Sinestro the Joker Black Manta cheetah
Gorilla Grodd it's cool to see because
this is one of those things where it
sort of brings back this old DC Comics
stuff now in reality I didn't expect it
to return that fast and so in this
instance you end up having Lex Luthor
literally who grabs like a material
that's capable of destroying Vandal
Savage and just beats him to death and
while that happens Vandal Savage
essentially reaches out to the mind of
Martian Manhunter and pours out every
bit of information that he can't pours
out everything about everything he knows
and some Martian Manhunter kind of
experiences this overwhelming sensation
and this vast amount of information but
when he races back to the Justice League
to tell them what's going on they've all
basically vacated believing that the
meeting was over and that was that was
really about it and so it's kind of a
cool thing here because what we end up
do
is basically picking up with like Jon
Stewart you know Jon Stewart being being
sought after by like Swamp Thing and in
essentially Batman it's kind of
interesting to have them have him sort
of a pop up out of nowhere really more
is like it's like mental constructs but
basically they're like we need you here
for a major crisis like you have to like
you have to come here now and so from
here we basically switch over to the
Justice League themselves who are
dealing with Killer Croc and it's kind
of crazy because Killer Croc like
whalers just kind of exploded and just
become like this massive almost
primitive being kind of reverted back to
being like a dinosaur and the reason why
this seems to have happened is because
he came in contact with the totality
which is to say whatever this object is
big crash-landed on earth and it's kind
of a crazy thing because at this point
we end up having a gorilla grodd and
really learning like gorilla grodd
cheetah
you know the Joker these guys have all
joined the Legion of Doom for their own
individual reasons and that's kind of a
way for Scott Snyder to feed on the
original basis behind the Legion of Doom
while rolling it into the story and
giving them a larger purpose because the
Legion of Doom was formed as a way
really kind of an old-school way of all
we're gonna destroy our individual our
individual heroes and here's how we're
gonna do it you know it's kinda like a
greater scheme imagine like the plan of
the Red Skull from old man Logan but
imagine that it never worked and that
was basically the Legion of Doom that's
really kind of the role they played and
so what we end up finding out is that
one of the one of the things that are
here is basically like this little baby
now we'll find out who this baby is and
what this baby is capable of but I I'm
not really sure what direction Scott
Snyder is going in because the baby is
totally different from the character
that it used to be so maybe it's just
kind of like a reworked version you know
I'm not really 100% sure but regardless
of the scenario the the whole plan the
whole idea of the Justice League at the
moment is to go find out what the
totality is because it's one thing for
some object who has to have escaped the
the the source wall and then basically
come headed towards earth and then it's
another thing for nothing to happen and
so when it just crash lands on earth and
then seems to mutate people that's
really about it now one of the big
issues that they face here is that
mutation happens on the cellular level
and so what you're talking about is
whoever has chosen to go in from what
Batman says the only people who wouldn't
be immediately destroyed by the mutation
or at least transforms right off the bat
would be Martian Manhunter and Superman
which makes sense because they're
physiologies are so intense and so
because that like Batman's whole idea is
we have to go like they have to be the
ones to go in
the longer they stay there the more
likely they will be to beat it you know
to be to be mutated and so what Batman
has done is use the technology of Adam
Ray Palmer and gone into Superman's body
and they don't know this they're like
where in the world are you is like I'm
inside Superman because I'm Batman and
I'm always serious I would've made a
joke I'd be like I'm inside Superman I'm
controlling him like the like what are
the jaegers from Pacific Pacific Rim
like I think it'd be kind of funny to be
honest but Batman's whole idea here the
plan they formed and in fact you're
actually gonna end up having hot girl
travel inside of Martian Manhunter
vision why this works so well is because
what they're going to do is basically
operate is kind of enhanced antibodies
because you're talking about cells that
are gonna be entering in I guess you
know kind of a some sort of biological
agent that's going to enter into the
bodies of Superman and Martian Manhunter
once they enter the totality the role
and battle of Batman and Hawkgirl will
be to travel throughout the body and
basically destroy those cells everywhere
they can find them so they're literally
gonna be playing the role of of an
antibody wall Superman and and Martian
Manhunter are traveling through the
through the totality and it's a cool
idea the problem with this is that as
Jon Stewart is making his way back to
earth he suddenly met by like this
massive force of energy and then Thal
Sinestro wielding a whole new source of
power and it's crazy because what Thal
Sinestro basically says here is you've
seen me wield like a yellow Lantern ring
in a Green Lantern ring but that's no
longer the case I am now wielding a
whole new aspect of the emotional
spectrum I'm basically wielding the
invisible emotional spectrum essentially
saying like a side of this latest source
of power that's never been heard of
before and it's kind of cool because
it's one of those things where just when
you feel like the lantern base couldn't
really be expanded anymore now it is and
essentially he just oozes control of Jon
Stewart and so while Superman and
Martian Manhunter are travelling into
the totality and while they're basically
being spoken to by the rest of the
Justice League who stay behind Jon
Stewart just smashes in and starts
ripping the place to pieces not only
that at the Legion of Doom this is where
things get so bad ask at the Legion of
Doom
everybody starts reacting and and
cheetah comes to this belief system that
Lex Luthor's lined and so in response to
this she goes to attack him claws his
face off and we end up finding out it's
a robot and the reason why is because
the real Lex Luthor is actually inside
Superman so is Batman and so Lex
Luthor's literally just biding his time
but at this point we
switch over to the kind of jump back to
the past and in switch 2000s sure and
the reason why this matters is because
for Sinestro himself while he was a
Green Lantern and then eventually kicked
out of the Green Lantern Corps because
he was using such heavy-handed tactics
once that happened he actually became an
explorer of the Stars and the idea here
was to go out there and see what power
was available outside of the Green
Lantern's what he ends up discovering is
some is a being of sorts called embrace
and there's basically this thing ah this
called the the ultraviolet spectrum more
or less but instead of being like the
traditional emotional spectrum which is
to say you know love and rage and and
the other aspects of the of the
emotional spectrum you know fear and so
on so unlike those which actually tap
into normal human emotions what this
does is it feeds into it it feeds off of
destruction and chaos basically places
where things have absolutely lost any
real measure of sanity and where there's
nothing but violence and chaos to be
found and so this this being um Brax was
discovered by Thal Sinestro and was like
this power has to be locked away this
power can never be accessed because if
it makes its way across the cosmos
it'll just seed chaos and war everywhere
goes it'll just start you know inducting
people into its ranks and so that's what
that's one of the cool things because
when it comes to Jon Stewart I mean he
is the kind of power he possesses here
it's still very much a nature of of what
a what a lantern can do in terms of
creating constructs the difference is
that he's feeding on the fear the chaos
like all these different aspects all
these different emotions more or less
the chaos of this situation is feeding
his power which in turn allows him to
create more construction so there is
essentially the the Justice League
feeding into these things
now Aquaman's the first one to realize
it and he's also one of the people to
fall but you also have basically Jon
Stewart wreaking havoc wrecking across
the entirety of the Justice League
itself the only person who's able to
step in here and actually bring him to
an end
is cyborg because sabor doesn't really
feel things the same way that a normal
person does and so cyborgs able to
basically knock him out and it allows
them to sort of deal to take him back to
the Justice League and her to the
headquarters and figure out what's going
on but we end up finding out this
totality that exists out there really
seems to be more of a reverse energy in
the sense that what it does is it
devolves things around them and so if
Martian Manhunter and if Superman were
to stay here long enough they would
devolve back into their most primitive
forms now how far back those primitive
forms would go we're not a hundred
percent sure the indication seems to be
kind of AD evolution and mutation at the
same time so they do
evolved to a primitive state and their
mutated in the process the issue with
this is that the armor they possessed
this is on to protect them isn't really
working effectively because of all the
conflicts they're engaging in and so
where you've got Batman and you've got
Hawkgirl flying through here and
basically just trying to destroy all
these different little antibodies that
exist out there
suddenly Lex Luthor attacks Batman from
behind and the idea from from what we
can gather the idea is to just see what
happens defeat Batman defeat Hawkgirl
and just see how things unfold not only
that switching back over to Jon Stewart
this is one of the coolest things one of
the things that I really really like
about what Scott Steiner did here is you
have Jon Stewart who essentially says
that when the ultraviolet light
basically takes over you that it
controls you you don't control it and
that's not really something that we've
seen before the closest we've ever
really gotten to that are the Red
Lanterns but it's not really even the
Red Lantern ring controlling you and
making you do what it wants you to do
it's just you become kind of like a
mindless beast and you do whatever
Atrocitus tells you to do so you lose
all siblings of self control and all
inhibitions and you just go and do crazy
things
but with this Jon Stewart was
essentially possessed it's like being
possessed by an apparition it makes him
do whatever it wants to do which is to
seed chaos war in conflict it was
awesome because it's a whole new concept
there and so it's basically him kind of
spilling the beans to the rest of the
Justice League saying okay look so there
are all these different forces out there
that were always held back by the source
wall now we can largely presume they
existed in a more primitive era of the
multiverse but we don't know who locked
them away all we know is that the source
wall was there to keep all those things
at bay and so what ends up happening
here is Jon Stewart basically says
because of the crack in the source wall
all these forces are starting to emerge
and that's when the flash chimes in and
says are you referring to things like
the still force and Jon Stewart's answer
is yes there's a still for is the sage
forced but there's also these other
fundamental forces of the universe that
we never knew about there were always
kept at bay and now they're here and we
don't know what impact they're going to
have on things
it's absolutely bonkers and so at this
moment we end up finding out this is
again just a chunk of the source wall
they just came flying out and
crash-landed on earth but there are
beings who are confined here who were
locked inside the source wall because
for whatever reason they try to
basically break out and they tried to
achieve the source the issue at this is
that as you end up having Lex Luthor
watch events unfold Martian Manhunter
does kind of has to know what's going on
and he starts going in there trying to
touch the source
trying to see what these various beings
are where they came from and that's when
one of them basically wakes up and says
you are an abomination here you're not
supposed to be here as it was kind of a
crazy thing because it seems to be
hitting home with this idea that the DC
Multiverse as it exists now is not
supposed to exist so it may turn out to
be that these people these beings who
are attached to the source wall aren't
there because they were imprisoned to be
there they're there as Guardians they're
there to you know their to be is to
essentially make sure that things travel
the way they're supposed to we don't
really know like it's it seems to be one
of these things where spiders kind of
going back and altering the entire basis
behind why this source wall exists what
the purpose is that it serves not only
that we also end up finding out that in
where you have Lex Luthor in the body of
of Superman that what you have in the
body of Martian Manhunter is the Joker
and it's pretty badass
because it really kind of begs the
question what would it be like if the
Joker possessed Martian Manhunter and so
at this point we basically end up
finding out that when Thal Sinestro had
to had essentially been sent by Lex
Luthor to discover another one of these
fundamental forces that is basically
unbrushed
you know in that that um brat should
basically escape following the crack of
the source wall and Thal Sinestro had
been tracking him down
and when Thal Sinestro found um brats
that was just their kind of seating
chaos among various worlds and different
things like that which allowed the
Sinestro to tap into its power seize
control of that power and then begin
expanding the ultraviolet port and so
where you have the unwatched entity
basically traveling around and allowing
itself to to basically immerse into
various worlds the next target the one
place the one place that draw a druid
here among all other places was Earth
because a planet is so chaotic and so
from this moment Lex Luthor essentially
destroys the ship of Batman which leaves
him free-floating hot girl is knocked
out by the Joker and this basically
leads to like Thal Sinestro going
through in attacking every single member
of the I guess attacking all the various
members of the Justice League and where
you have Jon Stewart who tries to hold
back as best he can ultimately it
doesn't matter and his ring is destroyed
by the power of thought Sinestro so this
is really kind of Scott Snyder saying
this power this this fundamental force
is well beyond the power of the
emotional spectrum not only that when
Gorilla Grodd shows up Gorilla Grodd
basically brings this baby which you
know the flash essentially refers to as
turtle and it's kind of a weird theme
because the original turtle was a foe of
jay garrick and he made various forms of
weaponry that were designed to mimic
turtle and that was really about it and
so this character seems to be like
wholly new it seems to be a brand new
character that we've never seen before
but it's a sage force conduit basically
meaning that it can freeze everything in
time it can ascend or not really freeze
everything but it can stop the movement
of everything around it which is exactly
what happens
Gorilla Grodd uses the baby and freezes
the momentum of everyone meaning the
flash the Justice League II and Aquaman
Wonder Woman the whole nine yards they
can't move not only that because of the
fact that the sage force deals with
aspects of the mind and so on what we
also end up realizing is that Gorilla
Grodd is essentially tapping into the
mindscape of a Wonder Woman and Aquaman
and tricking them into believing they're
seeing cheetah and Black Manta
respectively when in reality they're
attacking each other and so this is one
of the coolest things because this is
kind of Scott Snyder taking this
somewhat hokey team and then saying but
what if they were under the leadership
of like Lex Luthor who was pushing them
towards saying let's reach our full
potential from here you end up having
like again you know falsi destro
attacking everybody but not only that
you have him basically spread the
quote-unquote gospel of the ultra violet
court in the sense that all the power of
the invisible spectrum is scattered all
throughout earth and we end up finding
this massive core has been built by not
only thousand Estero but also by um
brats itself that this core this ultra
violet core
dwarfs the total sum of every other core
that's out there it's insane it's an
absolutely massive core because what it
would mean is that they could
essentially just lay waste her earth
just attack everything all at the same
time and so not only that you've
basically have Batman who's
incapacitated hot girl who's
incapacitated Lex Luthor who's in who's
in control of Superman's body and the
Joker who's in control of of Martian
Manhunter zhh body and seizing control
of them they push them into the totality
with the it with the opportunity to
seize control of this power and we have
no earthly clue what will come of it oh
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explained make sure you
guys at the sub button to become part of
the robb for free guys you throw this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you all later peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]